christian dufour et martin biron josé va
nous rejoindre dans une seconde bonsoir
alors revenons sur la conférence de
presse du jour martin d'abord premier
constat il n'ya plus besoin d'avoir des
faits nouveaux apportés à la population
pour tenir un point de presse monsieur
legault vous ne peut répondre à la
fameuse courbe qu'on a montré toute la
journée hier où le québec d'école que
les autres provinces reste en
augmentation beaucoup plus contrôlés et
là il est revenu de son argumentaire des
autres villes d'amérique du nord dakota
est américaine mais dire aux mystères
toronto c'est pour cela il voulait il ya
c'est entre autres pour cela martine
exactement ce qu'ils voulaient recadrer
son message est petit ça fait une
semaine locke ça gazouille un peu de
frima sur la ligne pour prendre une
image et que son message passe pas très
bien y est absolument incapable
d'expliquer pourquoi est-ce que la
courbe du québec monde si vite à
comparer aux autres provinces alors il
ya développé son argumentation était
vraiment bien préparé il ya parlé des
villes américaines se joue évidemment
c'est un comparatif peu douteuse
parce que quand même aux états unis on
n'a pas les mêmes leaders là c'est
justin trudeau donald trump on est on
n'a pas le même système de santé on n'a
pas la même culture alors la comparaison
est un peu boiteuse mais bon il voulait
quand même mettre un peu de perspective
et il ya choisi et on sent que la
critique latin parce que il a choisi
d'expliquer en disant écoutez il ya des
gens qui trouvent que je vais trop loin
il ya des gens qui trouvent que je vais
passer loin
en fait ce que je veux vous dire c'est
que je doit gouverner et prendre des
décisions fameux dames messieurs duda
messieurs dont il a repris d'ailleurs
aussi sur la question du racisme
systémique alors l'idée générale
aujourd'hui c'était vraiment de recadrer
son message alors qui a été quand même
assez absent de l'espace public r oui
christian ce que dit martine est
intéressant parce que moi je l'ait
vraiment compris comme ça aussi monsieur
legault qui a été sensible à la critique
là depuis plusieurs jours au plus il
écoute et leur
venez donc essayé ont pour certains pour
les pédiatres
on referme trop les écoles pour d'autres
on ne referme pas assez oui toronto ya
un mystère que je ne m'explique pas mais
quand vous bon plus sur la défensive en
même temps le plaidoyer reste le même
s'il vous plaît restez à la maison parce
que notre réseau de santé va en vacances
et il était sur la défensive le contexte
beaucoup changé je trouve depuis dix
jours parce que je casse le moral même
si damas a dû être très dur maintenant
pour les décideurs politiques au québec
le gouvernement l'avait eue je cacherai
pas facile au québec y avait très peu de
critiques c'est comme un discours un peu
une alim bien pensants et sanitaires
pour signer québécois en fait tu faisais
semblant pas voir que notre pin en effet
quand même pas très très très bon depuis
toujours en fait sursauter l'oeil de
plusieurs critiques l'opposition s'est
mis à poser des questions donc monsieur
le nouveau comme vous l'avez dit était
sur la défensive mais je trouve ça le
stimule et je lis rarement tous les
aussi convaincant voire france on baissa
gt5 qui allait au point
et puis répondre aux critiques que c'est
vrai et les gens qui trouvent que que je
donc on marchait pas assez qu'on va pas
si vite d'autres qu'on en fait mais moi
ce qui m'a frappé c'est à quel point on
est dans autre chose depuis toujours et
monsieur legault fausse elle stimule
tant mieux parce qu'il faut qu'il
défende son bilan eric salha josé
bonjour jose ca le pic est là
aujourd'hui
il voulait répondre avec aussi de
l'émotion avec d'un côté on n'est pas
parfait mais si quelqu'un la formule
donne hélas nous c'est pas
nécessairement une bonne chose à dire
pour un chef de gouvernement
parce que c'est quand même 8 qui est à
charge mais moi je dirais que oui les
stimule et comme le dit christian mais
on ressent aussi exaspéré et à raison
d'une certaine manière donc oui les
responsabilités du gouvernement ont
elles sont connues puis il ya eu des
gros problèmes de communication voire
pas le répéter ça a perduré jusqu'à
récemment
je dirais même avec votre entrevue avec
le ministre dubé il ya le milieu du gué
c'est un petit peu en partie leur appui
à la fin il ya comme acquis et c'est au
fait que les québécois seraient moins
discipliné c'est comme jouer aujourd'hui
mais on le sent surtout et qui est
inquiet de choses parce que ce sont des
objets en verre cette parenthèse je
venais mais où
pourquoi je vous dit que c'est une
erreur de dire que d'émettre l'hypothèse
que les québécois n'ont mois au moins
envie de respecter les règles qu'en
ontario peut-être mais c'est à dire la
question était bonne mais du point de
vue du ministre la santé et c'est pour
ça qu'il est revenu là dessus en point
de presse aujourd'hui c'est que ça a
donné l'impression même si t'as pas son
intention que s'est dédouané le
gouvernement et que ça blanc mais plus
les citoyens lorsque la réalité d'envoi
la shdm a partagé la auquel on a assisté
cet été le gouvernement aussi là il ya
pire pas été présent il est inquiète
réellement
ouais je devrais pas seulement du
système de santé puis pour des raisons
électoralistes parce que malgré tout la
popularité de monsieur gautier le coup à
travers la tempête c'est qu'il est
inquiet aussi je pense que devant ce
barrage maintenant qui s'érigent de
critiques que ça met des partis
d'opposition les la foire d'empoigné
cette semaine entre l'association des
pédiatres et d'autres pédagogue d'autres
médias qui était pas d'accord les
commentateurs comme ils nous appellent
ah bon aussi c'est que sa puce miner
encore plus une adhésion de la
population qui est déjà fragile du moins
dans une partie de la population pour ce
qui est des consignes et si ça ça se
passe déjà qu'il ya eu un relâchement
ben évidemment ben là on peut rentrer
dans ce scénario qui va être vraiment
pro bowl il est déjà pas au bout mais il
pourrait être beaucoup plus laid sur le
plat des morts sur le plat de
transmission communautaire etc
donc c'est parce qu'il doit jongler avec
tout ça en même temps donc oui le
secteur mais c'est notre travail de les
analyser mais en même temps l'adhésion
d'une partie de la population on le sait
elle est en partie inexistante et en
partie fragile pour d'autres j'ai envie
de poser une question oui je serai pas
long que ça je vais vous donner la
parole j'ai envie de vous quand même
vous poser la question sur est ce que il
vous lis trop bon je joue jose mais qui
donc est ce qu'il y trop sur les réseaux
sociaux à ce qu il est on sait qu robert
bourassa lisais tout peut parler aux
journalistes elle a devancé la dri
vasella sur landry 12 et payer nous
appelait km
vous avez compris mais est ce que est ce
qu'il est trop sensible à sa campagne il
ya quatre cinq chroniqueurs qui
s'apprend des masques à l'écart est ce
qu'il est trop perméable à sa christian
jacquet le jeu toujours a pas que
j'avais pas assez fier de doute que jean
fêteront plus que je suis dangereux je
pense que ce sera quoi il faut que ce
soit essentielle beaucoup plus qu'un
commentateur respect pour nous c'est de
faire tourner dans un contexte qui
fondamentalement différente du printemps
dernier au printemps dernier évidemment
c'est un cataclysme et c'est nouveau il
y avait une adrénaline défilement disait
ça va être temporaire leur maintenance
est pas totalement clos parce que les
gens semble qu'on s'enfonce dans quelque
chose qu'ils aient qui est déprimant les
restaurants sont fermés les théâtres
sont fermées donc à ce moment là
monsieur legault doit tenir compte de ça
c'est pas juste des des québécois qui
sont plus ou moins denses et le kayak
c'est que quelque part il ya des primes
très importantes qui s'est installé pour
qu'ils tirent plus qu'ils soient des
cours de taille des commentateurs martin
il est élu pour gouverner je pense
qu'ils gouvernent la nonobstant les
critiques c'est sûr qu'il est atteint
quand le milieu des affaires
l'interpellent le milieu culturel et
cetera mais le point de presse le plus
intéressant aujourd'hui c'était celui de
mylène loin quand elle dit
on a trop relâché on a baissé les bras
sur l'allier quelque chose qui a cassé
sur la dangerosité du virus et indique
qu est ce qu on veut essayer une
troisième wingles est-ce qu'on veut
jouer au yoyo ou est-ce qu'on veut
prendre des mesures qui vont être
durable et essayer de garder un rythme
mais elle semble dire que cet été on
avait beaucoup trop relâché et là elle
se projette dans l'avenir en disant cela
il ya des décisions à prendre et
peut-être que le gouvernement justement
est conscient qu'ils aient eu quelques
failles dans sa stratégie au cours de
l'été dernier oui on vous jamais été
aussi leur saint joseph un secret si oui
en sac une tension
d'ailleurs la tension entre la santé
publique montréalaise et la santé
publique nationale elle est là presque
depuis le début 1
on se souvient d'une entrevue le
qu'avait donnée l'adapter en milad du
boyau prétend reprocher à monsieur
harwood avec raison certaines de ses
décisions certains de ces conseils on
devrait dire hello tout à l'heure en
entrevue avec la mairesse valérie lance
la mairesse de montréal
les critiques envers le gouvernement
était à peine poil il a donc il ya
quelque chose et dans la cellule de
crise est normal ça fait six mois les
gens sont fatigués peut-être qu'il
faudrait élargir l'attend peut-être
qu'il faudrait y rentrer un peu de sable
et peut-être que je pense que jusqu'à 10
remplacé doctorat rudolph le point le
nom précis pas ça que je dis jeudi qu'
il ya des fois où quand une crise sans
précédent
bon alors une crise comme ça qui perdure
le québec est encore les puissantes
canadien de l'aco vide peut-être que ce
serait une bonne idée de rentrer du sang
neuf déjà avec un regard extérieur un
regard frais des experts là évidemment
alors papa dépend du commentateur 12
experts et est vraiment de brasser un
peu de brasse et un petit peu la cage
parce que le l'effet de bus de la
cellule de crise et je pense que la
réaction envers les médias en fait
partie elle est tout à fait normal
lorsqu'il ya un effet de bulle
ce serait bien la date n'a pas refait un
petit peu
écrit sénat en attendant le docteur
arruda y toujours là et moi j noter
quand même que le docteur en pays d'oc
refocaliser sur les fondamentaux en
disant aux gens ce que d'importants
c'est la distanciation des deux mètres
s'il vous laver les mains c'est les
masques étaient pas faire de parts ayant
même c'est beaucoup plus important que
toutes les autres interdictions et
fermetures et je pense que le défi du
gouvernement actuellement c'est de
contrer l'effet de déprime à long terme
parce qu on a accrédité l'idée qu'on
était là dedans pour un ou deux très
motivant pour les gens alors que le
message de monsieur legault qui était
assez convaincant je me suis convaincu
c'est de m'en donner dans un tournage
vient couronner la maintenant bientôt et
ça c'est très important parce que le
message je te dire là là on est installé
là dedans ça c'est profondément des
bâtiments pour les gens et en
particulier pour le tour les jeunes pour
la génération sacrifiée sur un très bon
coup je tiens à le rappeler beaucoup
moins utilisé cette expression là parce
qu'ils ont attiré l'attention sur
quelque chose de réellement j'ai défendu
les vieux au printemps dernier les gens
210 ha et plus je trouvais que c'était
vraiment pas correct déstigmatiser je
trouve qu est-ce que l'on va rater à
l'automne les jeunes moi j'aimerais que
coûte beaucoup trop sous-estimé très
bien mais la clé c'est la clip il cet
argent est ce que vous êtes vous 3 c'est
le temps le facteur clé c'est le temps
parce que vous voudriez vous a eu
aujourd'hui christian pascal d'y donner
un coup on va on va reprendre le
contrôle de l'augmentation des prix et
nos hôpitaux vont être capables de gérer
sa pige r il reste aussi mais si jamais
le temps allongé l'axé c'est là que ça
devient difficile jose un tifo qui a
donné de l'espoir
oui sinon les êtres humains c'est bien
pour le la solidarité aps la discipline
ça marche pas comme ça des trumeaux
mandela directement le goût de bonheur
d'espoir il faut que le gouvernement
garde ça dans son message
j'osais bas c'est pour ça que c'est à
mon avis à prendre un peu d'air frais
dans la cellule de crise est là si on
revient au jeune et c'est très très
important
les experts l'ont prédit depuis
plusieurs semaines la cotation
communautaire les jeunes deviendraient
des vecteurs potentiels de contagion et
que ça finirait par atteindre des
personnes vulnérables ce existe
damas que mylène drouin a expliqué très
clairement aujourd'hui c'est en train de
se passer et les jeunes le gouvernement
c'est pour pour l'accabler
mais y échapper il s'en est pas vraiment
préoccupés parce qu'on n'a pas fait on
n'a pas répété qu'au printemps on a
séparé le québec a deux bons il y avait
laissé hsl déplorait ça allait bien mais
ça ça fait du dommage aussi il commence
à être tard là pour parler aux jeunes
qui plus parlé avec des jeunes aux
jeunes qui pas juste des publicités donc
moi je veux pas dire que j'ai la recette
magique mais il ya des gens qui sont
connaissances sur ces questions-là des
spécialistes en communication qui
connaissent ces populations la peau de
la peut-être faire appel à eux
ouais comme on l'avait fait au tout tout
tout début de la crise avec lui des
influences
donc il ya des experts comme je
comprends ta déception avant de vous
laisser aller parce que je veux jouer
absolument finir un deux minutes sur le
débat américains vis présidentielle se
soit partir comme envoyer les les
prochains jours on doit vraiment prier
pour voir les chiffres diminué pour que
les efforts parce qu'on est des efforts
pas vrai qu'à pas d'effort les annales
les restaurants sont fermés les bacs
risan le souligner les musées les
cinémas toute la culture à montréal qui
est arrêté à ya alors on souhaite que ça
produit des effets mais il ya le court
terme le moyen terme et le long terme
allons-y sur le court terme c'est à dire
que on nous on nous dit en fait à la
santé publique que la semaine prochaine
on devrait commencer à voir les
résultats de la fermeture des bars des
restaurants et de cette consigne de
rester à la maison ne recevait pas alors
dès la semaine prochaine devrait
commencer à voir une baisse de comme on
verra probablement pas une baisse d
hospitalisation et une baisse des décès
parce que ce sont les personnes âgées
qui sont contaminés malade et qui en
meurent et ce sont les jeunes qui sont
content qu'ils se sont surtout
contaminés alors là ils ont commencé à
contaminer les personnes plus âgées à
l'on peut s'attendre à ce que les
hospitalisations continue à monter mais
la semaine prochaine il faut que le
nombre de quotidiens
baisse et ça c'est le chiffre à
surveiller et c'est là qu'on va savoir
si les consignes ont fonctionné merci
beaucoup martine je garde christian et
josé pas qu'on nous reste coi deux
minutes politique américaine qu'est ce
que vous allez surveillée de la dernière
semaine notamment été chargé on a
tellement l'impression de monsieur chaud
vous avez un papier très drôle très
drôle hein c'est pas drôle dans le fond
mais assez comique ce matin josé dans le
journal il dit malheureusement pas moyen
de trouver un seul puisqu'il ya parmi
eux parler de tous ces médecins qui sont
venus nous parler en fin de semaine et
parce qu'on a l'impression que ça
s'accélère un peu las
ces tweets et tout surveiller ce soir
josé bah écoutez je pense que je
surveille leur potentiellement la future
vice-présidente des etats-unis est
encore plus potentiellement la future
présidente des états unis si jamais si
jamais jobs hayden était élu président à
et devait quitter un moment donné donc
je pense que c'était un débat
extrêmement important ce soir
oui exactement et qui est d'autant plus
important parce que comme vous venez de
le dire
les deux mais dans le cas de cammalleri
ne sont plus probables peut devenir
présidente si il arrivait malheur à
monsieur par exemple s'ils souhaitent
pas non bien sûr que non encore eu lieu
de la future donc que je vais surveiller
moi je vais surveiller et ça c'est ce
qui m'a sauvé a fait l'honneur de la
démocratie américains parce que le
premier débat actuellement et hépatiques
c'était vraiment honteux de voir donc on
va le découvrir on y connaît - en fait
surtout site web
on connaît moins que monsieur madame ça
risque d'être plus gauche droite c'est
ce que c'est son monsieur monsieur
précisément mais mais en même temps moi
je te laisserais ce que m enfin ça peut
être un pays auquel heureusement des
gens ça peut pas être pire que le
dernier dix minutes par thème ça risque
d'être bien mené et
les plus respectueux comme vous dites un
rappel que c'est quand même une grande
démocratie on le souhaite
c'est à dire ce qu'on veut c'est avec
débat civilisé et non pas une bataille
de ruelle exactement ou deux merci
beaucoup émission spéciale à 20h ce soir
sur leur dis merci à la prochaine grande
soirée